I always say when life gives you lemons
make chicken piccata hi I'm Andrew I'm
the Test Kitchen manager here at tasty
and after a long day of working in the
kitchen there's nothing I like more than
sitting down for a meal with my wife but
ordering in and going out can be a
little bit expensive so today I'm
challenging myself to make five
weeknight meals for two for only $20
first things first I'm gonna run to the
store and see what I can find all right
so I was able to find everything that I
needed at the store for $18 and 76 cents
which means I came in under budget so
the dishes I'm gonna be making are a
sweet potato and chickpea curry a
one-pot chicken fajita rice baked and to
close out the week I'm gonna make my
favorite thing chicken piccata so
instead of having five meals for five
nights I'm gonna stretch my budget a
little bit more and have two meals twice
and then and out the week with something
a little bit special and helping me out
today are gonna be a few pantry staples
which I also recommend that you have in
your own home
those are butter olive oil salt and
pepper and with all that said it's time
to start cooking okay so first thing I
have to do is break down this whole
chicken which it looks a little
intimidating but it's actually a lot
easier than you think and very
inexpensive you want to lay it down with
the legs facing you you'll take your
knife and make an incision in the skin
right here between the breast and the
leg it should just come apart really
easy and do the same thing on the other
side the leg joints are exposed so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna put my hands
underneath here and then I'm gonna pop
the thighs right out of the socket I
want to take my knife and I want to cut
right on the opposite side of that
closest to the breast very carefully
obviously use a sharp knife when you're
doing this it makes everything easier so
here you have your chicken leg you have
your thigh and your drumstick now same
thing with the other one find the ball
joint get in there with your knife
carefully and there you have both
separated so I'm gonna set this aside
just over here I'm gonna bring the legs
back to my board turn them around and
you'll see right here there's this fat
line that's the exact place you want to
cut and separate the leg and the thigh
and you'll actually feel it with your
knife and just go straight through one
leg one thigh so now I'm gonna focus on
the white meat
the easy
way to get the breasts off the chicken
you have your breast plate here what you
want to do is you want to cut on the
opposite side of that closest to the
breast you want to remove and just make
a small incision this part is all about
the small incisions getting as much meat
as possible that's obviously the goal we
want to stretch our budget so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna keep going down
I'm literally just riding along the rib
cage trim back any of this fat from the
skin that you don't need remove this
breast goes to the skin it's all about
small strokes and there you have one
chicken breast the other one same thing
ride the rib cage when you can trim back
any of this fat cut around the wing
there you go two chicken breasts alright
so my chicken is broken down and the
nice thing about this is I'm gonna be
able to use all these parts of the
chicken in different dishes to really
stretch my budget but I'm not gonna
discard this carcass this is gonna
become a delicious chicken stock our
chicken stock is really just gonna be
chicken salt pepper and water you could
use aromatics if you want onions carrots
celery most chicken stocks have them but
since it isn't in our budget we have to
work with what we have so I had the
chicken to the pot then I'm gonna add
water just to cover and just salt a
couple cracks of fresh pepper but we're
gonna let this come to a boil bring it
down to a simmer and let it simmer for
about four hours to extract as much
chicken flavor as possible I guess I'll
see you guys in about four hours so what
I want to do is strain this out get all
the chicken bits out and just have a
nice clean stock
be careful once all the pieces come out
let's taste it it's actually really nice
I'm just gonna add a little bit more
salt just for myself stock is all
strained out it's season to my liking
I'm gonna use this in the majority of my
cooking today whatever's left over I'll
keep in my fridge for a week and then
I'll throw it in the freezer if I don't
get around to it so now it's time to
dive into our first recipe first thing
I'm gonna make is a sweet potato and
chickpea curry this is gonna be enough
for two dinners for the two of us so
first thing we want to do get our heat
going let's go over medium heat
we'll add some olive oil so once your
oil is nice and warm and shimmering
we're gonna add in some diced onion I'm
gonna give this a stir just to get the
onions all coated in the olive oil I'm
gonna season it with a little bit of
salt just because I like to season every
step
the way it's guaranteed excellent flavor
well we don't want the onions to burn we
just want them to sweat out a little bit
and soften just to bring out their
natural flavors while those are cooking
I'm gonna grate some fresh ginger right
into the pot most people think you have
to peel the ginger but I find that it's
a bit of a taxing step so we're just
gonna grate it straight in I'm gonna
give this a stir get those flavors all
together
looks like our onions are good to go
what I want to do now is I want to add
in some freshly minced garlic again just
adding extra flavor give it a stir you
just want to cook it until it's fragrant
you don't want to burn it it'll get
really bitter nobody likes that so now
we're gonna add in our curry powder what
we're doing is we're toasting the curry
powder we're really drawing out that
flavor and making the flavors really
warm now it's gonna taste good the first
day but the leftovers are gonna taste
even better when these flavors have had
time to marry and sit in the fridge
together there's nothing better than
that
the curry is nice and toasted so what I
want to do now is add everything else so
we have our chickpeas for a little bit
of protein and we have our sweet
potatoes I'm a seasoned all right so
we're gonna get these vegetables coated
in that beautifully toasted curry powder
and now I'm gonna add some coconut milk
give that a stir
I'm gonna do a little seasoning and next
we're gonna take this delicious chicken
stock that we already made we're gonna
add this right in here now we're using
chicken stock because we want it to
stretch the chicken and and save our
budget but if you do have it in the
budget to buy some vegetable stock this
would be a wonderful vegetarian dish
we're gonna bring this to a boil we're
gonna reduce it down to a simmer let it
simmer for about 15 minutes until the
sweet potatoes are perfectly cooked
through
well my curry is simmering away I'm
actually gonna toast some extra curry
powder just add a little extra flavor so
we can get some curry in a hurry we have
our heat our oil just a little bit so
now the oil is nice and hot I'm gonna
add in our curry powder and we're just
gonna carefully toast this until it
starts to smell fragrant and nutty like
I said this is gonna add so much curry
flavor to this already delicious curry
this will happen really quick too so
don't even blink safe to say that that
is smelling fragrant and delicious and
it's ready to get added to our curry now
I'm gonna add in some spinach and I'm
just gonna cook it for about two minutes
so it gets nice and wilted
this in its gonna look like a lot but
it's gonna shrink down to nothing and
then just to finish this off a little
bit I'm gonna add a little bit of acid
so I'm gonna add some lime juice alright
this looks really good I have two
Tupperware containers here full of
cooked rice rice is really inexpensive
and I'm also gonna use it in another
dish I'm making today if you want to
check out our tasty 101 video on how to
cook rice click below so what I'm gonna
do is I'll spoon my curry over the rice
do it over the pot curry will stain your
countertop this is gonna be really
really good in a couple days so I'm
gonna let these cool I'm gonna transfer
them to the refrigerator for later on
the week the rest of this I'll heat up
later on when my wife comes to try let's
move on to the next recipe the next
recipe we're gonna do is a one pot
chicken it'd be heat or rice bake this
recipe is really nice because we can use
the majority of the chicken that we
already broke down and then we can use
the other half of the rice that we
didn't use during the curry recipe and
like with the curry this is gonna cover
two meals during the week I'm just gonna
add a little bit of our olive oil we
don't want to use enough to just coat a
nice and thin layer on the bottom of the
pan so season our chicken a salt and
pepper on both sides so we'll flip it
over with some tongs we're gonna use two
of the drumsticks two of the thighs and
one of the chicken breast the other
chicken breast were gonna save for our
final dish of the week we're just gonna
use a store-bought packet of fajitas
seasoning I'm gonna use about a third of
it to season the chicken and then I'll
use the remainder of it later on in the
dish same thing will go in on both sides
we really want to get as much flavor out
of this as possible and these be heat of
spice packets I grew up on these things
everything my mother made had a spice
packet whether it be tacos or chili okay
so now I'm gonna rub the chicken get all
those spices into it get under the skin
if you can any excess spices on the
sheet tray you can just Pat right onto
there just want to make sure we're
getting every inch of this delicious
chicken that you spent all the time
breaking down coated with the spice if
you have any extra left over just do the
same thing dump it on we'll really get
it in there our chicken is all seasoned
it's time to sear it up so I'm gonna add
everything in skin side down so we can
get that nice crispy skin you could use
skinless chicken thighs but I just
really really
love crispy chicken skin and a lot of
the fat is gonna drip down into the rice
which is gonna make it taste so good
evenly spaced apart you don't want to
crowd the pan too much so I'm gonna let
this go for about two to three minutes
per side just till it gets nice and
golden brown we'll flip it over and then
we'll finish off the dish I'm just gonna
take a little peek under the chicken
just to make sure it's getting nice and
brown not burning it starts to burn you
can move it around the pan every pan
kind of has a different hotspot so oh
we're almost there
you don't really have to worry about
cooking the chicken through at this
point you're really just getting some
color on the skin it adds a lot of
flavor it cooks out a lot of those
spices a lot of the cooking is gonna
happen a little later on in the recipe
our chicken is nice and golden brown on
one side oh that's perfect so we're just
gonna do the same thing on the other
side let it go for about two to three
minutes I'm gonna go ahead and take it
out of the pan transfer it to a nice
clean sheet tray I know you can't smell
it but this smells so good and you don't
have to tell anybody it's a Paquita
packet our chickens done so I'm gonna
finish off the rest of the dish we're
gonna start with our vegetables sliced
onion and green bell peppers Green is
actually the cheapest one in the store
so that's what we're working with today
we've already built all the flavor in
the pan you've got chicken juices you've
got some of the flavor from that I'm
just gonna add the vegetables to our and
we're gonna season with salt then we're
just gonna cook these down until they're
nice and softened about two to three
minutes we don't have to worry about
cooking these all the way through
because it's gonna finish off in the
oven
give them a nice toss get it all coated
in that already-built flavor in the pan
so while these onions sweat they're
gonna release a lot of their natural
juices which is gonna pick up a lot of
that really nice flavor in the pan so to
these vegetables I'm gonna add about a
cup and a half of rice I like to add the
rice in at this step just so it toasts a
little bit gets a little bit of nutty
also adds extra flavor and then to this
I'm gonna add the remainder of that
bejita packet I was talking about
earlier give that a stir get everything
coated so once all the rice is nice and
coated in the spices we're gonna add in
our homemade chicken stock we're gonna
go in with about two and a quarter cups
of this chicken stock give it a mix let
it come to a little simmer scrape off
the bottom of the pan if there's any
nice browned bits all right this is
simmering so I'm gonna go ahead and add
our chicken pieces back in so I'm just
gonna nestle these in here just to make
sure that it cooks all the way through
and don't forget all these beautiful
juices so I turn up the heat you're
gonna go ahead and cover this with some
foil a fun little trick
to make sure the foil gets nice and
tight pinch the bottom and twist all
right and this is good to go we're gonna
transfer to a 400 degree oven for 35 to
40 minutes until the internal
temperature of the chicken is a hundred
and sixty-five degrees Fahrenheit
oh my god that looks so good I'm gonna
take half of this and I'm gonna save it
for later on in the week let's get the
thighs my favorite cut of the chicken
that should be enough and then we'll get
some of this delicious rice and
vegetable situation oh it smells so good
I don't know if I can wait until later
on the week so when it's time to serve I
also bought sour cream salsa and some
lime to really jazz up the flavors a
little bit all right
I'll serve this later when Claire comes
here and now we're ready to move on to
our final recipe our final dish of the
week one of my all-time favorites
chicken piccata first things first we
got to tackle this lemon I always say
when life gives you lemons make chicken
piccata I'm gonna go ahead and I'm gonna
cut this lemon in half crosswise I'm
gonna cut this guy in half these guys
I'm just gonna cut into really thin
slices about an eighth of an inch thick
so a little trick when you're cutting
any vegetable or fruit is to just keep
your hand in a nice slaw formation so
I'm gonna go ahead I'm going to transfer
these to a really small bowl these are
gonna go into our sauce later on in the
dish and the juice of this is actually
gonna go into our sauce later on as well
so that's our lemon now we're gonna move
on to the chicken we have our last
chicken breast here you're probably
wondering why do you have one chicken
breast I was gonna make two meals we're
actually gonna go ahead and cut this in
half and it's gonna make to thinner
chicken breasts so to take off the skin
you only have to do anything fancy you
can really just peel it back use some
force and voila so to get to cutlets out
of this one chicken breast you want to
take your knife you want to use your
other hand as force and then really thin
strokes through the center of this
chicken breast making sure that we get
all the pieces you can kind of see you
can open it up this way and then slowly
slice away at it
till you get to perfect chicken cutlets
one and two we're gonna pound these out
really thin it helps the chicken cook a
little bit faster and it's also very
traditional to chicken piccata I'm gonna
take one large piece of plastic wrap and
I'm gonna place it over top of these
chicken breasts with the flat end of the
meat mallet we're just gonna pound away
at these chicken breasts what I like to
do is
going directly down I'd like to almost
go in an upward motion and I would say
you're looking for these chicken cutlets
to be about a quarter of an inch thick
this may seem like a really small amount
for two people but it's gonna be over a
bed of pasta it's gonna have a really
delicious and buttery sauce so it'll be
all good so I'm just gonna season it
with salt and pepper give it a little
flip and it a little sprinkle a little
pepper I'm so excited for this this is
literally one of my favorite dishes I've
put some oil in the pan we have to
dredge our chicken and a little bit of
flour so we used all-purpose flour here
very inexpensive at the store and I'm
gonna add this to the pan lay the
chicken cutlet down away from you so the
oil doesn't splatter I get this guy and
nice and coated and now we're gonna cook
these for two to two-and-a-half minutes
per side and nice and golden brown then
we'll flip do the same thing and then
we're on to our sauce all right our
chicken is done nice and golden brown on
both sides it's gonna transfer this to a
clean plate with a pair of clean tongs
all right so it's time to make our sauce
into the same pan we're gonna use all
the chicken drippings as our oil we're
gonna cook some garlic about two cloves
of garlic we just want to cook that
until fragrant we don't want it to burn
we're already starting to brown so I'm
gonna add in our capers the capers are
nice and briny to add a nice salty note
to this chicken piccata also one of the
classic ingredients in the sauce I'm
gonna add in our lemon slices these are
gonna cook down and release their juices
naturally so when your garlic starts to
get a little too golden brown we're
gonna add in our chicken stock this will
stop the cooking it'll also bring out a
lot of the flavors lemon is the very
iconic flavor and chicken piccata so
just to really drive that home a little
bit I'm gonna add some freshly squeezed
lemon juice so we're just gonna let this
cook down for a couple minutes until
it's reduced by half so the thing about
chicken piccata at me is this is
actually the first thing I actually
learned how to make I think I just kind
of always gear towards the lemon flavor
of things I really love super acidic
things so when I first learned how to
cook I was like that's the first thing
I'm gonna learn how to do so the sauce
is reduced down by half I'm just gonna
turn off the heat and then we're gonna
add our butter so this is about two
tablespoons of butter ideally a nice
cold pad or butter and what I like to do
is I actually like to swirl it into the
sauce this way it gradually just kind of
thickens the sauce stops it from
breaking I can smell the capers the
garlic
really coming through you can see how
creamy and emulsified that butter is in
the sauce it's really really nice
alright that looks perfect our sauce is
done it's exactly where I want it to be
just to add a little bit of color I'm
gonna throw in some fresh chopped
parsley save a little bit for garnish to
turn off the heat and now it's time to
plate it all up I'm gonna serve it over
pasta pasta really hearty super
inexpensive so pasta on the plate and
then I just want to gently place the
chicken breast over top like so
and then use our delicious sauce spoon
all of that at the top this is also
gonna become a sauce for the pasta to
make sure we get it right on nice on top
there I'm gonna put more capers on mine
but that love capers I'm just gonna
finish it off with a little bit more
fresh parsley just for some color and
that's it the final plate of the week
now my wife's on the way here so I'm
gonna go ahead and plate everything else
up before she arrives and then we're
gonna taste it and we'll see if she can
guess how much it all costs we did it
we've got everything plated up we've got
five weeknight meals for two for just
under $20 now all that's left to do is
to have Claire come in and try it - see
you - oh wow so do you think this is
enough meals for the two of us for the
whole week I mean I would think so yeah
I live off the leftovers so we'll start
with the first day okay so this is a
sweet potato and chickpea curry mmm
that's delicious hearty enough for oh
yeah you can eat this two days out of
the week done we have a one-pot chicken
pita rice bake perfect all right
ooh good color you taught me that I
don't know I'm talking about good yeah
that's a really good blob that chicken
is cooked perfectly
this is like our first four days okay
and then finally on Friday I made you my
favorite which is the chicken piccata ah
Italian mix-ins
hmm right oh my god big question is how
much do you think all of this costs this
is a lot of food all of this um what
like 25 bucks 18 dollars and 76 cents
worked on $89 76
that's impossible you're a magician yeah
Wow good job thank you yeah thank you
for cooking for me Oh anytime
I so appreciate it anytime so it just
goes to show that even on a tight budget
you can still make it work make it
delicious and maybe even oppress a
pretty lady oh if you guys have any
occasions that you want us to attempt on
a budget please let us know in the
comments below take care oh oh yes
[Music]
you